merci d'être avec nous pendant cette
première vidéo
du Val-d'Oise apparenté au groupe les
républicains manque de reconquête cette
partie d'Éric Zemmour et vous êtes le
rapporteur du budget immigration asile
intégration va bien sûr longuement
parler dans quelques instants d'abord un
mot sur le covid puisque c'est aussi
l'actualité de cette semaine les
chiffres qui remontent Elizabeth borne à
lancer un appel à la responsabilité à
porter le masque dans les transports en
personne de présence fragile vous
partagez cet appel
non enfin je partage pas cet appel car
le gouvernement est même pas successifs
qui ont menti et on devrait s'intéresser
à ce qui a été dit ce qui a été fait
depuis deux ans que chacun fasse
attention en fonction de son état de
santé de forme d'âge évidemment quelque
chose de normal je considère que les
Français qui se sentent pas bien mais
qu'il met un masque qui se leur fait
plaisir qu'il mette en bas si ça les
rassure moi je considère
toi même en protégeant les autres
quelque part il se trouve que je prends
les transports en commun difficilement
comme les Franciliens qui hier il y
avait effectivement dans le RER B
horaires qui est bien bondé aux heures
de pointe donc on laisse passer parce
que même sans grève on a quand même du
mal à monter dans le verre à la gare du
Nord il y avait quelques personnes avec
le masque et bien libre à eux de le
mettre c'est une bonne chose
effectivement que les personnes fragiles
qui apparaissent un certain âge on
incite les gens en se vacciner et bien
pourquoi pas mais surtout pas qu'on
retombe dans les travers de la
contrainte pour tous et notamment pour
les jeunes qui ont été vaccinés alors
qu'ils ne craignent rien du tout et avec
apôtre problème de responsabilité et de
la responsabilité de ce gouvernement
vous avez signé avec 53 autres sénateurs
une tribune en valeur actuelle on
soutient à votre collègue sénateur Alain
on perd il est sénateur de Côte-d'Or il
est radiologue et il s'est vu signifié
une interdiction d'exercer durant 6 mois
par l'Ordre des médecins pour avoir
stigmatisé l'inutilité et l'inefficacité
des vaccins justement protégeant de la
propagation du covid ça vous paraît pas
normal cette
est-ce que vous venez de dire lui s'est
élevé sur la contrainte vaccinale pour
tous hein et et là c'est déjà sur le ce
qui oublie reprocher c'est ça donc
c'est pas tout à fait ce que vous venez
de dire la avec le recul vous pouvez
normalement être d'accord tous les et
ceux qui sont honnêtes
intellectuellement la légitimité de
vacciner toute la population contre ce
vaccin se pose d'autres pays ont choisi
différemment la Suède et d'autres pays
et là donc déjà sur le sur l'objectif
poursuivi la question médicalement se
pose là c'est la question du
parlementaire français qui n'est pas
libre de son expression de son opinion
dans le parlementaire les sanctionnement
en tant que est-ce qu'il est
parlementaire avant tout médecin qui
répond à un ordre les parlementaires
français sont protégés dans leur là
c'est s'apparente pour moi un délit
d'opinion parce qu'aujourd'hui ça veut
dire qu'il y a deux parallèles il y a
deux sortes de parlementaires ceux qui
sont parlementaires comme moi il y a
personne mais pas de profession
réglementée et d'autres parce qu'ils
sont médecins parce qu'ils sont
architectes parce qu'ils sont huissiers
etc de formation et serait leur parole
serait limité ça pose la question de la
liberté d'expression et une fois de plus
et en ce moment on voit bien de cet
exemple est frappant moi-même en tant
que parlementaire il y a quelques années
Twitter avait coupé mon compte pour
simplement avoir rappelé la loi sur une
femme en burqa
j'avais trouvé bien peu défendu par
l'institution sénatoriale et là il y a
une cinquantaine de collègues qui
n'ayant pas tous le même avis
effectivement sur les questions des
vaccins pour tous et donc là la question
se pose simplement c'est une imitation
de l'expression de la liberté d'un
appartement et c'est grave
l'examen du budget évidemment et hier
vous avez rejeté le budget asile
immigration intégration dont vous êtes
le rapporteur on va voir les temps forts
de cette séance avec Quentin calmé
[Musique]
bonjour Oriane bonjour Sébastien Laurent
et Quentin les crédits de la mission
immigration asile intégration donc été
rejetée
à la quasi unanimité contre lui on va
commencer par la droite par vous vous
avez jugé qu'il était le symbole de
l'impuissance publique et de l'absence
de volonté en matière de régulation de
l'immigration c'est ce que vous avez dit
à la tribune du Sénégal ce budget sur
l'immigration l'asile l'intégration et
pourtant en hausse de 6% par rapport à
l'année dernière mais selon Muriel
Jourdain qui était rapporteur pour avis
de la commission des lois et bien un
budget en hausse ça ne fait pas tout
écoutez la sénatrice
un budget c'est la traduction d'une
politique l'abondement d'un budget n'est
pas une politique avant nous une
politique migratoire légale et illégale
sur ce territoire je ne le crois pas
nous traitons les problèmes au fil de
l'eau il va falloir définir une
politique c'est ce que nous ferons je
l'espère voilà la droite très critique
la gauche également elle juge de son
côté et que ce budget ne va pas assez
loin pour permettre un accueil digne des
immigrés écoutez Guy benaroche et lui
écologiste des Bouches-du-Rhône
notre pays sonore est senorgueille
d'accueillir et de sauver a juste titre
c'est l'entraîneur je regrette que cette
honneur soit variable entre l'Aquarius
et l'océan Viking par exemple chers
collègues n'y voyait aucune naïveté ni
aucun idéalisme utopique mais au
contraire entendait le besoin de bien
accueillir de mieux respecter les
demandes des personnes arrivant sur
notre sol ne serait-ce que pour leur
intégration et pour l'avenir de notre
pays alors parmi les sujets qui ont fait
l'objet de plus de commentaires il y a
notamment la question du taux
d'application des OQTF les obligations
de quitter le territoire français on va
écouter un dernier extrait de ce qui
s'est joué hier en séance parce que en
plus les critiques là elles viennent des
indépendants qui sont pourtant un groupe
de la droite Macron compatible écoutez
sénateur
une polémique coupe depuis plusieurs
années maintenant si ce n'est plusieurs
décennies celle de la très faible
exécution des obligations de quitter le
territoire français
voilà 10 ans que le taux d'exécution ne
dépasse pas les 20% les trois dernières
années il était en dessous de cette pour
cent
faire une loi et ne pas la faire
exécuter si autoriser la chose qu'on
veut défendre disait des chiots et
mettre ses obligations et ne pas les
exécuter c'est affaiblir notre droit
voilà le Sénat a donc rejeté ces crédits
hier en séance et on a vu au passage
combien ces sujets sont clivant entre la
gauche et la droite de l'hémicycle des
clivages très forts que l'on reverra
bientôt Oriane puisque le gouvernement
doit présenter et ça a été rappelé en
séance un texte sur l'immigration au
début de l'année 2023 pourquoi avoir
rejeté ce budget ou pour nous expliquer
c'est pas une surprise il n'y a pas de
politique migratoire en France là c'est
un collègue de la Réunion
intéressez-vous à ce qui se passe à
Mayotte en ce moment même c'est ce qui
préfigure ce qui va se passer en France
sur d'autres territoires
mais Mayotte c'est la moitié de la
population est clandestine la moitié de
proximité géographique avec les Comores
que la Seine-Saint-Denis ne connaît pas
alors écoutez nous avons la Guyane à
proximité du Suriname nous avons des
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
viennent en France sous les ans on
accueille 400 à 500000 personnes
légalement tous les ans une partie de
ces personnes arrivent et là mon
collègue de gauche cité l'océan Viking
les derniers battes l'Aquarius
ces personnes qui arrivent on a beau ne
pas effectivement les Comores c'est
quand même il y a quand même des il y a
quand même la mer à traverser donc là la
moitié de la population est étrangère
clandestine alors la moitié de ceux qui
sont légaux la moitié est d'origine
clandestine ce qui pose le problème de
l'accueil et de la capacité d'accueil
aujourd'hui je considère que nous
pouvons plus accueillir dignement il
suffit simplement d'aller porter la
chapelle il suffit de se renseigner moi
ça fait 5 ans que je travaille sur ces
questions là
les auqtf on va en parler
en France on subit la loi des passeurs
et c'est des passeurs qui sont des
passeurs criminels sont les organiseurs
criminels donc l'état français est
complice de cela ce qui est absolument
terrible en quoi elle était en quoi les
tailles on laisse faire on sait d'où
partent les bateaux mettez-vous disons
en arrière il n'y avait pas ses passages
de ces tentatives de passage il n'y a
pas ses morts en Méditerranée c'est mort
dans la Manche donc et aujourd'hui vous
n'avez pas nous faire croire qu'avec les
satellites on ne sait pas d'où part de
ces bateaux et on sait très bien que
certaines ONG sont complices de ces
trafiquants c'est l'ancien ministre
Castaner qui est quand même pas passe
pas pour quelqu'un de virulent qu'il
l'avait dit est forte années mais que
peut faire l'état français tout est bien
tout simplement dire c'est terminé on
arrête on raccompagne le droit de la mer
c'est les premiers ports donc là on sait
très bien que le dernier bateau a enfin
les lois de les droits de la mer c'était
exceptionnel
Darmanin c'est pas une politique
migratoire d'accueillir d'accueillir
tous les autres personnes
combien de demandeurs d'asile plus de
120 000 plus de 130 000 là on parle de
ce qui est légal l'État français c'est
un rapport parlementaire de 2018 d'un
collègue est-ce que en marche rodwick
cocondo corniche
seul département du 93 à 100000 200000
voire 400000 prêts le nombre de
clandestins 2018 rapporte parlementaire
suite à des auditions vous savez comment
ça se passe service de l'État donc
l'état ne sait pas combien il y a
d'étrangers clandestins on va parler des
hôpitaux oui c'est on l'a entendu
pendant la discussion du budget hier
c'est ce qui fait le l'objet le plus de
critiques on a un taux effectivement
d'application qui est très faible on l'a
dit 20% ces dernières années même encore
en baisse ces trois dernières années
au-dessus de 6% c'est ce qu'a dit le
sénateur comment expliquer qu'on
n'arrive pas à reconduire davantage les
personnes dégoûtées du droit d'asile
dans leur pays alors là c'est pareil
c'est un entre le discours et les actes
vous avez Emmanuel Macron président de
la République deux fois président de la
République quelqu'un qui avait travaillé
pendant quatre ans avec François
Hollande déclarer en 2019 on va faire
exécuter 100% des déclarations des
locuteurs ce qui paraît légitime bon euh
ça vous paraît un objectif est
atteignable à condition de vouloir 100%
qu'on soit un peu moins que moi aussi
des pays qui peuvent ne pas vouloir
reprendre les ressortissants c'est le
cas c'est le problème c'est un sujet qui
on pourrait développer c'est pas en plus
de 5 minutes mais il se trouve que je
connais j'ai décortiqué le mécanisme
c'est un sujet d'abord diplomatique là
vous imaginez bien que les printemps
arabes se créent l'ouverture des prisons
les voyous sortent bah les personnes les
États sont contents de s'en débarrasser
qu'est-ce qu'ils font ils viennent en
France et ils savent très bien qui
bénéficient d'un logement de soins etc
donc les 6% de critères vous rendez
compte c'est pour ça les tous les autres
pays européens font mieux on est dernier
de la classe on comment augmenter ce
taux selon vous alors là c'est d'abord
je vous ai dit diplomatique nous étions
nous aidons le Mali nous aidons les pays
d'Afrique de manière générale parce que
ça va d'abord des pays qui ne sont pas
forcément en guerre là il y a évidemment
les Syriens les les Irakiens mais là les
principaux flux viennent de pays qui
sont dissurent Algérie Maroc etc Albanie
donc là dessus ces pays n'ont aucune je
veux dire légitimité à ne pas reprendre
leur recensant poids diplomatique c'est
extrêmement facile si on le veut que
l'Algérie que le Maroc reprenne ses
ressortissants arrêtons de rigoler
il veut diminuer le nombre de recours
ils veulent diviser par 3 il veut que
les préfets leur rendent la vie
impossible je cite il veut que ces
hôpitaux elles sont inscrits au fichier
des personnes recherchées est-ce que du
coup vous allez soutenir ces mesures
paroles paroles
je soutiens je le cas problème je passe
sectaire comme certaines la gauche si
c'est un sujet qui est primordial pour
l'avenir du pays il faut sortir de
l'idéologie des petites phrases il faut
poser le problème ça fait des années que
je demande donc à mon groupe ce qu'on
appelle un droit de tirage pour calculer
le coût d'immigration pour décortiquer
on sait pourquoi on est aussi mauvais ou
je viens de nous dire nous sommes les
derniers de la classe dernier de la
classe c'est à dire que les petits pays
comme le Danemark ont résolu les
problèmes des pays comme Malte font
mieux que nous nous sommes l'Allemagne
fait mieux que nous nous sommes les
derniers donc il y a des raisons
objectives à cela on l'a dit un texte
sur l'immigration qui est prévu au début
de l'année de l'année prochaine est-ce
que je vous dites c'est il peut y avoir
une main tendue vous votez les mesures
qui vont dans le bon sens de ce qui a
été présenté par Olivier duapay et
Gérald Darmanin quel est quel est votre
opinion sur le problème c'est que on est
plus dans le on doit plus être dans le
discours que ça se faire donc évidemment
les textes qui vont dans le bon sens je
les voterai le problème c'est
d'application de nos textes
l'application de nos lois c'est vraiment
ce texte doit permettre rien de l'a dit
de mieux appliquer les de mes appliquer
les les règles en la mesure de diminuer
les temps de recours ça peut être des
choses qui vont dans le bon sens que
vous voteriez mais tout ce qui va dans
le bon sens je le voudrais simplement
s'il ne faut pas tromper les Français le
en même temps sur tous les sujets
aboutis à ce que je viens de voir 6%. 6%
alors qu'on a un président qui voulait
faire appliquer
des occultés vous mesurez dans l'écart
le gap Gérald Darmanin effectivement
c'est ce que le ministre a dit ministre
karaoké
dans dans les discours mais très bien
simplement c'est que les Français on
voit bien moi je suis allé au port de La
Chapelle j'étais écouté c'est pour
personne ils sont des frites et des
criminels le trafic d'êtres humains le
rapporte aujourd'hui plus que le trafic
de drogue donc c'est c'est il y a des
gens effectivement qui se noie malgré
tous les efforts plus de la moitié du
droit administratif français relève du
droit des étrangers plus de la moitié
est-ce que vous iriez jusqu'à remettre
en cause le droit d'asile mais un
maillot c'est déjà ça quelque part
puisqu'on a déjà il y a quelques années
voté un texte qui limite au rasie mais
la question évidemment se pose la
démographie on sait comment ça se
passait le continent africain va
continuer à avoir le plus en plus
d'habitants et évidemment la question se
pose c'est d'accueillir les gens
dignement le directeur général de l'OFI
passe pas pour quelqu'un forcément de
droite et qui connaît la question et
disait l'hospitalité pour
[Musique]
continue à avoir une législation
différente il faut savoir que Mayotte a
voté pour Marine Le Pen
principalement Mayotte est une
population d'origine enfin ethniquement
noir et culturellement musulmane ils ont
voté pour Marine Le Pen ça devrait
interpeller les belles âmes de gauche et
droite aussi qui n'osent pas dire les
choses les faits les faits les faits
merci Quentin merci Oriane à tout à
l'heure dans le club on va parler de la
présidence des LR et ce sera la suite
dans un peu plus d'une demi-heure on va
aller voir l'actualité dans nos régions
maintenant Sébastien Morand on va à la
Nevers on retrouve Philippe de Pal
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
Philippe du Journal du Centre et en une
du Journal du Centre comment la France
se prépare au coupure d'électricité
oui bonjour Effectivement aujourd'hui
sur deux pages
du centre et d'autres types du groupe
Centre France effectivement se penchent
sur ces coupures d'électricité à lancer
pour cet hiver
pour cela nous avons visité un des 28
centres d'edis où les agences préparent
de voir effectuer ces coupures
ponctuelles de 2h alors bien évidemment
il y a des levés d'action d'abord
insisté au déco gestes aux actions de
sobriété énergétiques et puis agir a été
fournisseur d'énergie pour lisser des
pointes de consommation si c'est merdes
si ces mesures ne permettent toujours
pas de retrouver un équilibre entre la
production d'électricité et la
consommation
c'est à ce moment que des baisses de
tension pourraient être appliquées et je
voulais savoir imposer la question à
Sébastien Morande est-ce que vous avez
l'écran par rapport à ces éventuels
coupures d'électricité plus que des
craintes là c'est un sujet que je
connais particulièrement
est en fils d'électricien euh lorsque
on constate que cette année pour la
première fois depuis 80 on est un
portateur d'électricité avec le parc de
Sandra nucléaire que nous avions c'est
un scandale d'État la gauche avec
Monsieur Jospin donc ça nous remonte à
97 pour faire plaisir à Madame René
avait arrêté superhénix qui venait
d'être accordé au réseau et bien cette
gauche là avec Monsieur Hollande et avec
Monsieur Macron continue cette politique
de limitation production d'énergie et
l'énergie c'est enfin c'est c'est de
l'économie transformée enfin l'économie
c'est de l'énergie transformée plutôt
donc ça va toucher tous les secteurs
d'activité et c'est malheureusement un
constat que nous sommes en voie de tiers
mondialisation comme dans certains pays
et bien il y a des coupures
d'électricité nous allons vivre ça et
les causes chercher les causes les
causes c'est effectivement cette remise
en cause de l'énergie nucléaire qu'on
avait un atout absolument incroyable en
France c'est que 80% de notre mix
énergétique reposait sur le nucléaire en
moyenne il y a quelques années et avec
le l'hydraulique on était à presque 100%
d’énergie non carbonée aujourd'hui se
dire qu'on relance les centrales au
charbon Saint-Avold et autres ça fait
quand même mal au cœur alors qu'on avait
cet héritage gaulien qui était
permettait d'être indépendant nous avons
audité cette semaine au Sénat ancien
patron du commissaire à l'énergie
atomique qui qui qualifie l'arrêt
d'Astrid c'est pour les neutrons rapides
donc arrêté par Monsieur Macron le
président actuel de décision stupides et
plus cyniques parce que on a quelqu'un
qui en même temps a fermé Fessenheim
c'est lui qui l'a fermé ses fenagne
alors que EDF avait investi des
milliards d'euros et qui nous parle et
c'est effectivement les médias les
grands médias relais et bien nous allons
rouvrir les centrales nucléaires donc
comment faire et bien évidemment ils ont
anticipé ça ils nous préparent ils
préparent l'opinion allez couper le
courant ce qui est extrêmement
inquiétant parce que nous avons bien des
personnes qui sont isolées enfin fonde
pas loin de enfin en province ou
ailleurs et bien si vous avez plus de
téléphone quand vous appelez les secours
sur un problème de santé et justement
Philippe vous êtes aussi intéressé au
risque d'approvisionnement plus sur le
long terme oui tout à fait dans
l'empêche nous avons une interview de
Nicolas Goldberg qui a expert en énergie
pour
Columbus consulting et il dit qu'il est
pas trop inquiet pour cet hiver mais que
il est beaucoup plus pour les années à
venir et d'ailleurs je le cite
il nous a dit ce sera compliqué chaque
hiver en fait tout dépendra de la
provisionnement du hangaz en Europe les
stocks sont remplis en quasi totalité
pour cette année mais est-ce que ce sera
le cas l'an prochain et en ce qui
concerne notre parc nucléaire
aujourd'hui dans un état inquiétant on
sait déjà que pour l'an prochain les
prévisions d'EDF ne sont pas bonnes ça
peut donc mal se passer et donc une
question si ce problème persiste dans
les années à venir quel subventions
selon vous pourrez devrait être mise en
place un gouverner c'est prévoir vous
avez bien compris que la politique
notamment nucléaire française depuis
quelques années un certain nombre
d'années maintenant est une folie la loi
Nome aussi donc là ça concerne un peu la
droite et cette suggestion à suggestion
à la politique européenne et notamment
le calcul du prix du gaz c'est difficile
en quelques minutes mais vous savez très
bien que c'est le l'énergie est devenue
un au nom d'une idéologie de
libre-échangisme de soi-disant de baies
d'ouverture de la concurrence pour faire
baisser les prix c'est un échec et qu'en
France le prix de l'énergie soit quelle
ville sur le prix du gaz qui est devenu
un objet spéculatif est un scandale
absolu l'Espagne le Portugal s'en
sortent beaucoup mieux parce qu'ils ont
sorti de ce prix de l'énergie donc
évidemment quand monsieur Macron on va
ouvrir les centrales nucléaires c'est
son successeur son successeur parce
qu'on claque pas des doigts on s'en
ouvre pas une centrale nucléaire comme
ça donc la cour moyen terme je ne vois
pas et là c'est un sujet géopolitique
c'est qu'on a la décision européenne
d'arrêter les l'approvisionnement et
l'arrêter dans les mots c'est pareil
vis-à-vis de la Russie on se prive du
principal fournisseur d'énergie de
l'Europe du jour au lendemain c'est une
décision politique et on importe leur il
fallait continuer et bien il y aurait
certainement fait du continuer et il y a
qu'au moyen terme je répond la question
on ne peut pas se priver à court moyen
terme du principal fournisseur d'énergie
de l'Europe donc là on va apporter à
prix d'or un gaz de schiste américain
donc la question se pose à court moyen
terme comment peut-on faire et bien soit
on soutient l'économie et il faut
trouver du gaz parce que il y a le prix
il y a aussi la capacité à avoir de
l'énergie donc là il y aura peut-être
une récession donc là il y aura
peut-être moins effectivement besoin
d'énergie mais à court moyen terme je ne
vois pas comment diversifier au maximum
les approvisionnements y compris et
surtout c'est que intéressez-vous au
fait et aux causes l'Allemagne
aujourd'hui ne peut pas à moyen terme
donc il y a moyen terme 5 10 ans se
priver de de l'énergie russe et là ça
pose les questions des décisions
politiques
erratiques scandaleuse prise par les
dirigeants européens et français bien
sûr aussi et on a bien compris votre
point de vue Sébastien Morand on va
remercier Philippe depal comment la
France se prépare aux coupures
d'électricité c'est à la une du Journal
du Centre aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous on va terminer par
quelques questions politiques puisque
vous avez démissionné des républicains
vous étiez membres des républicains vous
avez démissionné mi-mars pour apporter
votre soutien à Eric Zemmour j'imagine
que vous allez quand même regarder jeter
un oeil ce week-end sur l'élection le
résultat d'élection à la présidence des
républicains est-ce que selon le
vainqueur vous pourriez revenir aux
républicain non moi j'ai militaire
j'ai je suis venu à la politique par par
passion je mets je viens du privé et là
c'est le système de l'intérieur que j'ai
vu en tant que parlementaire en tant que
membre de la commission nationale
d'investiture je ne veux pas souvenir
moi je revenir
moi je mets
quel que soit la ligne la ligne c'est
différent mais moi je pense que les
républicains ne peuvent pas gagner tout
seul donc je suis pour une alliance
allez au sens large et on n'a pas le
temps de développer des patriotes de
tous ceux qui mettent la France au
toutou c'est pour ça que je suis prêt à
voter avec en marche avec sur des sur
des sur des questions fondamentales et
la question ça doit aller d'où
l'alliance moi je plaide pour l'Alliance
pour simple aussi l'alliance des droites
même général de Gaulle en 65 n'avait pas
la majorité au Parlement et je vous
parle du général de Gaulle donc là il
faudra se mettre d'accord sur ce qui est
essentiel parce
essentiels pour qu'on soit clair c'est
LR le rassemblement national Éric
Zemmour et oui et puis les
souverainistes de gauche parce que je
mets la droite dans les amoureux de la
France voilà avant tout et là quand
j'entends parler le président de la
République française qui parle d'Europe
alors qu'il devrait descendre des
intérêts de la France moi je parle pas
de souveraineté européenne ça n'existe
pas je parle de souveraineté de la
France qu'il faut reconquérir sur tous
les plans donc effectivement élargir sur
ce qui est essentiel la question de
l'immigration est une question
essentielle parce qu'elle touche tous
les aspects de la vie sociale donc et je
pense moi il faut reconstruire l'état
reconstruire la nation en construire la
démocratie sur ces questions de fond je
vous disais un référendum donner la
pouvoir au peuple de décider c'est le
peuple souverain en dernier ressort et
là dessus je pense que ça soit les LR
que ce soit reconquête que ce soit le RN
que ce soit même les souverainistes de
gauche et bien on doit pouvoir se dire
qu'on donne à Para au peuple mais en
fonction de la ligne vous allez regarder
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y a une
ligne en républicain qui peut se tourner
vers cette union des droites et oui
parce qu'en fait
c'est toujours pareil entre le discours
les actes moi ce que dit aujourd'hui
Bruno Retailleau et alexioti moi j'ai
soutenu il y a un an je l'ai accordé ma
confiance tout de suite pas quand il
était près de gagner un contrairement
parce que je crois aux idées je mets des
idées d'abord avant les personnes donc
tout ce qui va dans le bon sens je
soutiens je suis d'accord et ce que dit
Bruno avec ce que dit Eric et après
c'est comment faire
Marine Le Pen pour faire cette alliance
l'important c'est pas c'est pas
l'alliance des états major c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on propose comme projet aux
Français les Français ne votent plus à
50% parce qu'ils n'y croient plus il ne
croit plus en LR il ne croit plus le RN
ça fait ça fait plusieurs fois qu'il
Marine Le Pen est qualifié il n'y arrive
pas
que liée un contrat de gouvernement et
que ça leur rassemble toutes les
personnes de volonté et je sors je vous
élargie vous voulez pas me restreindre
corner de la droite extrême droite les
personnes de bonne volonté moi je crois
à ça la politique c'est avant tout des
idées c'est des gens sincères et
honnêtes merci Sébastien merci merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité dans
20 minutes dans le cadre des territoires
on va aller en Loire-Atlantique on va
prendre un petit peu de recul actualité
on va aller à la rencontre de deux
grands enfants qui fabriquent des jouets
mais fabriqués produits en France pour
ça sera une idée de cadeau pour pour vos
enfants et vous laissez notre place
d'abord à votre prochaine invité c'est
Jean-Marc Ayrault qui nous rejoint